good morning everybody you're very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on Sky News Liz truss and
quasi-quarting have already been forced
into two u-turns on plans to abolish the
top rate of income tax and the date of a
major statement about the public
finances now a new Rebellion is growing
among conservative MPS over a planned
squeeze on public spending and potential
benefit Cuts our political correspondent
Joe Pike has been asking what's next at
the Tory conference in Birmingham
was the next U-turn Chancellor
are you going to be cutting the welfare
budget next
are you going to keep benefits as they
should be inside we will be taking the
due course and I'll really look forward
to talking to you about it then thank
you
the government should uh upgrade in line
with inflation the previous government
said uh it was going to so people are
expecting this is that the next battle
do you think well I hope not because I
hope the government is clearly started
listening but what about benefits our
bracing benefits in line with inflation
is that something you want to see well I
I've got of course every politician
would want to see that if there is a
case whereby we are going to be you know
going through difficult times then the
government must communicate that and be
honest with people and explain how and
what needs to happen next well there's
always fact to trim uh and uh there
there is considerable wastage in
government that's a sad reality uh
identifying it and then uh getting rid
of it without cutting essential Services
is the real challenge
into the Justice secretary Brown and
Lewis in just a moment or two before
that let's have a look at what's
happening as far as the papers are
concerned the financial times reports
that after his tax U-turn the chancellor
will shift on the timing of his debt
slushing plans in further you turn four
like the guardian says embolden Rebel
Tories are gearing up to block
reductions in public spending
particularly benefits according to the
times former Home Secretary Patel will
fire a conference broadside warning the
Tories will live or die by their
economic credibility the Miracles that a
Calamity conference and says that
regardless of the tax you turn the
damage is done while the Daily Mail
exclaims get a grip the express strikes
a positive tone with a call from Liz
truss for readers to stick with her and
a promise to reward their trusts
as promised to Justice secretary and law
Chancellor Brandon Lewis is with us this
morning good morning Mr Lewis thank you
for joining us on uh the program the
U-turn yesterday High rate of tax
um on the face of it it does appear that
it was there to appease back benches
like Michael Gove you wouldn't have got
it through the commons if there'd been a
vote on it
um what's the point in having
convictions if you cave on them at the
earliest opportunity
well we also regularly have a situation
where people criticize politicians for
not listening and I think what you've
seen is the prime minister and the
chancellor listening to what they heard
not just from colleagues but more widely
as well recognizing the issue and the
challenges with the 45p decision and
therefore saying look we've got a big
package here a package about growth
package helping the most vulnerable in
society that's what we want to focus on
this has become a distraction we've
heard we've listened we get it and
that's why they've removed it and I
think actually look you know as
politicians listening to people is what
we we're expected to do and I think it's
right that we've done that okay so there
could be more mini budget u-turns then
well I think the rest of the budget and
the whole point is we've got 95 of the
budget is going forward that uh quite
aquatang outline it's about growth it's
about helping the most vulnerable in
societies arguably the biggest package
to support people on energy that we're
seeing pretty much in the western world
and certainly across Europe and we want
to focus on that and I I think it's
right that that's what we do so is that
ruling out u-turns or not
well look as I say in government you're
always looking at what you can do what
you can do better what you can deliver
better for people in in the future but I
think we've got a package that is a
strong package it's a package that says
the world that the UK is open for
business so I think we will deliver the
rest of that package as it is it says as
I say to the world the weapon for
business that the UK is a place to
invest that it's competitive globally at
a tax level that encourages business who
are domestic businesses to grow and
employ more people and international
businesses to come here and join the UK
economy and grow their business here as
well that's good because it doesn't just
employ more people it means more tax to
improve Public Services further in the
future okay so you say getting through
the rest of the 95 of the package as it
is in an interview this morning six
times the Prime Minister apparently has
refused to rule out further uh u-turns
was her determination to get this
through
well I think she has got to tell us to
get this through look what we've seen
with the Prime Minister already is
somebody who she outlines in the
leadership campaign the core principles
she stands for that's what we're
delivering it's what we're still focused
on delivering which is a lower tax high
growth economy moving our country
forward to be able to create the jobs
and higher wages for people in the
future and to see growth go back to a
real a growth level that we'll recognize
as growth trying to get to that two and
a half percent we've had a very very
long time of uh stability that's meant
lack of growth and that is not good for
the economy we need to do something
different what the chance of the Prime
Minister set out is a different pathway
I think it's a pathway that will deliver
the growth we want to see that is good
for the whole country it means everybody
in this country is going to have the
ability to earn more money they're going
to have a tax cut for around 30 million
people in the period ahead as a result
of the announcements we made that also
means that there is more money through
the tax that we get when people spend
money when people earn money when
businesses invest when businesses grow
all of that goes into help fund our
brilliant Public Services
yeah you're saying get through this
economic plan as it is the prime
minister is really six times not ruling
out a further U-turn is she talking to
her cabinet
oh well look I told the Prime Minister
regularly actually and obviously we had
a cabinet conversation just a couple of
days ago so yeah she does talk to the
cabinet and what's really good about the
Prime Minister I have to say in my
experience in the early weeks of being
in this job is that she trusts her
Secretary of State to get on and run
their departments the chance to trust us
to get on and run our budget that's how
we can get things done that's how the
Department of Justice we've already been
able to expand our tagging program has
been out just a few days ago we're
looking at what more we can do to
support vulnerable people particularly
women who are involved in rape and
sexual offenses cases going through the
courts getting their Court backlogged
down and trying to make sure we've got a
package there that can end the strike
that we're seeing with criminal
barristers to get Justice to people more
quickly I can do that because the prime
ministers put the trust in me as a
secretary of state to deliver it yeah
but you didn't know as as did all the
rest of the cabinet about the slashing
of 45p down to 40p until it was actually
announced the Prime Minister told us
that herself
um last week when did you know about the
U-turn in this top rate of tax
well look two things okay first of all
decisions that are made and
announcements that are made as part of
budget are often and generally oh I have
to say my experience being in cabinet
for a few years now
um are kept to the chancellor because
they're not only Market sensitive but
they should be announced to to
Parliament first so there's Market
sensitivity around some of these things
so actually I think that's quite a
normal and common process I got a phone
call very early on Monday morning about
the change to to remove the 45 as I say
I think where something like that's
become a distraction for me phenomenally
positive and a big package to help
people across the country I think I can
absolutely see why the chance of the PM
have done it and I support them in
looking at what we are doing to deliver
for people across the country okay it's
not just grant shops it's not just
Michael Gove that are scratching their
claws Nadine Doris who used to be the
culture secretary she's also been
tweeting saying widespread dismay at the
fact that three years of work has
effectively been put on hold no one
asked for this
um she wants she thinks that there
should be a new mandate for this
government which would in other words
mean an election do you think that's a
good idea
look no I think the public have had
we've had a lot of germination a very
short period of time and I think we've
got a couple of years to the Next
Generation I think the public wants to
see us particularly at a difficult time
we're going to let's be frank we are
going to go into a very difficult winter
for people that's why we've put this
substantial package to protect people
from even further challenges with Energy
prices particularly in place I think
people want this get on and deliver on
that job that's how we ensure that at
the next general election we can win I
think we can win I have to say and I
remember Generations in the past people
tell us we're going to win with massive
majorities in 2017 and that didn't
happen I remember being told in 2015 we
were going to lose obviously we won that
election so the polls are a snapshot in
time we as colleagues have to be focused
on what we're doing to deliver for
people and I have to say I'm at
conference I was back in London
yesterday morning for the opening of the
legal year but on Saturday Sunday and
yesterday evening when I was here with
the members I've seen a really positive
um sort of atmosphere around Conference
of people wanting to get on with this
and deliver for people okay the Prime
Minister writing in the telegraph this
morning saying I want to bring the
public with me I want to win hearts and
Minds because I really believe my plan
is the right one for the country less
than two weeks ago she was telling our
Beth Rigby that she was happy to be
unpopular does she no longer believe in
herself
oh she does and I think the two things
actually are a complimentary point
they're not mutually exclusive uh look
what the prime minister's outline is
there are difficult decisions the things
we have to do to move the economy to
change the way we're doing this it will
change can can have disruption and this
is a big change in how we deal with
economic policy in this country in the
sense that although we would obviously
ensure that we remain fiscally
responsible and the chances outline that
and he's got his auction statement on
the 23rd of November which will set out
that medium term plan that people want
to see but also making sure we do move
to a lower tax economy that can drive
growth and what the Prime Minister I
think is rightly saying is that she does
want to show people why that is the
right thing to do but she is prepared to
do the difficult things in government
that is sometimes the job we have to do
for the right reasons and does that
stretch to capping arise in benefit
payments to average earnings rather than
inflation which would be a difference
between us well I think five and a half
and 10 so half of half as much
well I think we're getting into
conjecture there is a process around
this the department of work and pensions
Corey Smith the Secretary of State Works
through that over the Autumn she will
make some announcements around that I'm
not going to pre-jarge what that will be
but what I would say to people before
people
um get too concerned about this is we've
got a track record as a government for
many years right through covid and most
recently in this package that the
chancellor announced of doing everything
we can to protect the most vulnerable in
society that has been a driving force
for this government we've done that
consistently I know the prime minister
is focused on ensuring that we are still
doing everything we can to protect the
most vulnerable people but as I say the
benefits structure is one that goes
through a proper process we've got to
let that process happen and the work in
pension secretary will speak to that in
the near future but during the Autumn I
mean it wasn't a conjecture because I
wasn't making a statement I was asking a
question do you think that oh no I
appreciate that look yeah absolutely but
but what I mean is people are wondering
about what will happen with the benefits
structure and what the changes will be
if there are any is something that goes
to a proper process the decisions around
that are something the working pensions
team work through and they will make an
announcement through the course of the
Autumn we've got to let them do that
work first what I'm saying for people
though is the underlying principle with
this government has had consistently
through challenges whether it's the
Ukraine war covid has been to protect
the most vulnerable in society that's
why we're seeing those people getting
1200 pound benefit actually through the
announcements that the chancellor made
just a couple of weeks ago sure but
should benefits rise with inflation
yeah no problems I was just asking where
the benefits in your opinion should rise
with inflation
well that's tend to be into pre-judging
the decisions
well it has because every the problem is
when we're in the cabinet we all have
Collective responsibilities so it's not
just my opinion when I'm speaking I'm
speaking on behalf of the government I'm
going to let the working patients
actually do her work I do want to make
sure and I'm very supportive of the work
we've always done as a government as I
say which is protecting the most
vulnerable in society okay given that
you're a member of the cabinet and
Collective responsibility you would
expect to be involved in that decision
making
well I'd say all these things tend to
get discussed through cabinet there is a
there's a difference with Market
sensitive things around the budget
that's always been the case through
consistent cabinet but all of these
things the things that go through
cabinet yes okay but then um if you do
decide that it needs to be with average
earnings rather than um inflation then
you've got those big beasts that can't
be tamed like Michael Gove and Grant
shapes again who've already made their
position
um clear
um and the Prime Minister might find
herself in another damaging U-turn how
much do you think that is in the back of
her mind when she's making policy
decisions now
well I've got to say my experience of
working with the prime minister is she
tends to focus on what is right for the
country and what is going to get the
best outcome for people right across our
country look we do work in a
parliamentary democracy that means we
have to work with Parliament we've got
to make sure that what we're doing uh
can pass in Parliament as well that's
just a reality of a parliamentary
democracy I saw I heard the a clip from
what Grant was saying to you earlier and
Grant was making the point even with
welfare benefits it's about making sure
that whatever you do you're clear about
what the argument is that you can show
people why what you're doing is the
right thing as I say with quasi's budget
is one part of that we we could have
rolled the pitch better we've been open
about that that's why we've moved that
away with the welfare system as I say
the team at the department of work and
pensions and Cody Smith the Secretary of
State I'll work you through that at a
moment and they will be making a
statement on that this Autumn but these
are not Junior MPS these are people that
were sat around the cabinet table with
you until a month ago not necessarily
with Michael goes but certainly as far
as Grant chaps is concerned you have to
take their views and opinions into
account surely
well one of the things I'm sure that the
team will be doing is looking at a
couple of things one is obviously people
are always going to be listening to
what's out there we've shown actually in
the last few days I probably shown that
she is listening to people that's why
she's made that change with the 45p rate
so yes we do listen to people but the
team at the department of work and
pensions have also got to work through
the numbers to make sure that whatever
they are proposing their source and
works for people can deliver what people
need and as I say it sticks by that core
principle of doing what we can support
the most vulnerable in society
there are suggestions that there is some
fat to be cut out of departments in
order to try to save
um some monies
um what that mean for your department
given that there's a massive backlog in
the court system
oh well I think it's something I know
low so it's a few years ago now when I
was running businesses as well but one
of the things you always do in business
and one thing I think is right the good
that we're doing government is always
looking what can you do more efficiently
where can you save money both in terms
of that means there's more money saved
the executive that's good for the
general public or more money you can
spend on other Frontline services so
looking at how you do things more
efficiently is good practice every
business person in the country tends to
do that and certainly it's a good thing
for us to do in government I'm certainly
going to be doing that in my department
for example looking at the core
processor system yes we've got a an
unacceptable backlog that's why I want
to see an end to the criminal Barrister
strike we put forward a really strong
positive package which I hope they'll
accept and we can start getting on top
of that backlog but there are other
things we can do as well around how we
modernize how we use technology we're
doing some of that for example in making
sure that for vulnerable women who are
involved in rape and sexual violence
cases do not necessarily need to be in
court they can use technology and record
their evidence separately we're seeing
with prisoners rather than spending
money always moving them between prisons
and courts we're spending money to put
technology in so that they can give
evidence from a secure room in prison as
well so there's a whole range of things
we can do and I will always be looking
at how we do things more efficiently and
effectively that's part of my duty to
the public and the people of Great
Britain is keeping them safe and doing
it efficiently
let's end where we started just to
clarify you see a U-turn as a position
of strength rather than weakness despite
a quote from a certain lady 40 years ago
that still resonates today
well she's a great lady and she uh I was
very fortunate she was the vice
Chancellor my University and gave me my
degree look the reality is I think
what's good is that the Prime Minister
feels strong enough and confident enough
to to have listened to people to make a
decision to be able to move on and focus
on this huge package of support we're
putting into for people that will give
not just tax cuts to 30 million people
but give that extra protection around
Energy prices and inflation to the most
vulnerable people in our country so
u-turns are not a weakness
look I think sometimes when you when you
deliver when you're develop developing
policy and delivering policy you've got
to listen to people I think uh generally
people criticize politicians for not
listening and you've got a prime
minister who has listened to them the
chancellor has listened and they've
acted okay it's great to talk to you as
always thanks so much indeed for joining
us much appreciated thank you
thank you good morning
good morning still to come on the
program for you does the government's
economic strategy undermine National
Security talking to the defense
committee chair that's Tobias Elwood
political biographers that Anthony
Selden gives his take on whether the
government can recover lost credibility
and as new pills show labor maintaining
commanding leads that's over the
conservatives you'll get analysis from
pollster and Tori Pierre and Lord
Hayward
[Music]
North Korea has fired a missile over
Japan causing Air Raid Sirens to go off
in Tokyo
[Music]
people across Japan were warned to take
cover as the missile passed overhead
before landing in the Pacific Ocean
Phoebe Amarosa is in Tokyo for us this
morning hi Phoebe good to see you um
tell us more about what's happening
well it was a very alarming wake up call
for Japan and that's as in this case we
need to provide an intermediate range of
missing missile over the country and
this is the first time that North Korea
has quite a missile over Japan since
2017. it's also believed to be the
longest flight flying around 4 600
kilometers and this one's just after
South Korean official said last week
that Mars has completed preparations for
a nuclear test and could conduct one
imminently so we've seen a very strong
International response condemning
pyongyang's actions are prime ministers
they're outrageous and Japan says that
all options are on the table and that
includes Counter-Strike capabilities and
that would be a big step for Japan which
has a
constitution that would really be
beating up its defenses
also said it's it's committed to its
sense of Japan and South Korea but has
stressed that the devil remains open for
dialogue with me
okay um good to talk to you at one or
two technical issues but we're certainly
getting the sense of what you were
telling us there uh keep safe Phoebe
thank you
and Ukrainian troops have broken through
Russian defenses in the South and
expanded their offensive in the East
let's find out more should we die on a
standing by for us in Moscow uh this
morning this is not going to be happy
reading in Moscow is it Diana good
morning to you
not really especially okay after the
ukrainians retook the city of liman in
the north that they've now made advances
around Curson in the south at kerson
counter-offensive that's been
telegraphed for a long time and also the
Russians have been admitting to it we've
heard from the Kremlin appointed head of
the kerson region that they've taken
several Villages around ordudichani one
particular Village which is on the
danipro river and the defense Ministry
also confirmed that the ukrainians had
broken through the Russian lines just
north of Duty and also just south of
kerson and apparently the Russians had
retreated and were inflicting massive
fire on the enemy they said but it's
interesting to see the defense Ministry
acknowledging these kinds of losses and
also to hear the reaction on Military
blogs which have been very critical of
these losses that the Russians have been
sustaining programming military blogs
and also increasingly on State TV we're
seeing much more Frank discussion about
the fact that this is a long and hard
fight and that the Russians aren't doing
particularly well which obviously comes
off the back of all the sort of fanfare
around the fact that mobilization wasn't
really being managed particularly well
we've had Rams and kadiroff the head of
the region of chechnya lay blame on the
commanders who lost liman and called for
them to be replaced and that's also from
the the head of the mercenary group
Wagner Evgeni pregosian has also come
out publicly and attacked the Russian
command and there's also reporting today
that or last night in fact that the
leader the commander of the western
military District in charge of liman has
been replaced
um by another so a reshuffle at the
ministry of Defense just from one
Russian Source we have that at the
moment I think the fact that you're
seeing this kind of discourse on public
channels suggests that you know it is
not as tightly controlled as it has been
there could be two reasons for that one
is that people are just really worried
and beginning to speak frankly in ways
that we've not seen before opening
really a Pandora's box of criticism the
other of course is that it does prepare
the public for an even more dire
situation where Vladimir Putin can claim
that he was compelled to use even more
dire weapons which is of course
something that he has been threatening
over and over again now
um his uh nuclear talk his claims that
he is not bluffing and I suppose if
State tv prepares the people for what
they're calling a a a Russian losses
against not Ukraine really but a a
larger NATO he could feel Justified to
claim the need to use
more deadly Weaponry okay Diana thank
you
in other news the Royal Navy is sending
a submarine Hunter to the North Sea to
help protect oil and gas pipelines the
move follows the apparent sabotage of
gas pipelines off the coast of Denmark
which some Western countries have blamed
on Russia let's get more should we Emma
standing by for us at the ministry of
defense this morning hi Emma tell us
more
yeah so this ship has been sent to the
North Sea to work alongside the
Norwegian Navy and according to the
ministry of defense is to provide
reassurance for those working near the
gas pipelines however I think what we
can be clear about is that this is about
more than reassurance it's about also
providing protection and also a sense of
deterrent because oh it's strongly
thought that underwater explosives were
used to cause the four leaks in the
nordstream one and two pipelines that
run from Russia to Germany huge volumes
of methane escaping into the North Sea
and Russia has denied any involvement in
that instead pointing the finger at the
west but what has become clear and was
made clear by Ben Wallace the defense
secretary of the conservative party
conference is that this has really
flagged up the vulnerability of this
kind of infrastructure whether it's
cables or whether it's pipelines and
that something needs to be done to
provide protection and yesterday The
Joint expeditionary Force which is made
up of 10 northern European countries got
together and and decided that they do
need to increase the presence in the
North Sea to act as that kind of
deterrence and just one other thing to
add and that is that the defense
secretary has also said that the UK will
be acquiring two new kind of ships
they're called multi-role survey ships
for seabed Warfare now one will be
fitted out in the UK available operation
for operations by the end of next year
and another is also going to be built
from scratch and this all about ramping
up this protection for crucial
infrastructure
okay thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now let's start with
immigration the Home Secretary will set
out her plans to deal with illegal
immigration later on today with the
government's controversial Rwanda
deportation policy being challenged in
the courts swella bravaman is expected
to ask the French government to do more
to stop small boats crossing the channel
and attempt to make deportations easier
the man charged with the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell will
remain in custody until he faces trial
in March 34 year old Thomas Cashman
appeared at Liverpool magistrates court
yesterday before the case was referred
to the Crown Court he's also charged
with the attempted murder of Olivia's
mother Cheryl and of Joseph knee the man
he chased into their home
the inquiry into the UK's pandemic
preparedness when covid hit is due to
begin later the preliminary hearing
delayed during National morning for the
queen will outline the schedule of the
inquiry and what it will investigate
public hearings are due to start next
spring
looking at the weather if you know
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
next few days will bring wind and rain
but Southeastern Britain looks mainly
fine and dry
top stories for you so far this morning
the Justice secretary Brandon Lewis has
this morning tell me the government will
deliver the rest of its mini budget as
is following u-turns on the top rate of
tax and the timing of the next fiscal
statement however the Prime Minister has
refused to rule out over u-turns
Japan's prime minister has decried what
he calls a reckless act after North
Korea fired a ballistic missile over
Japan and into the Pacific Ocean
[Music]
Ukrainian troops have broken through
Russian defenses in the South and
expanded their offensive in the east
prime minister says she's going to take
a responsible approach to handling of
public finances amid a fresh battle
against Tory rebels over the level of
benefits earlier the Justice secretary
Brandon Lewis told me the prime minister
is working for the benefits of the
country despite admitting the government
could have rolled the pitch better on
its mini budget
my experience of working with the prime
minister is she tends to focus on what
is right for the country and what is
going to get the best outcome for people
right across our country look we do work
in a parliamentary democracy that means
we have to work with Parliament we've
got to make sure that what we're doing
can pass in Parliament as well that's
just a reality of a parliamentary
democracy I saw I heard the a click from
what Graham was saying to you earlier
and Grant was making the point even with
welfare benefits it's about making sure
that whatever you do you're clear about
what the argument is that you can show
people why what you're doing is the
right thing as I say with quasi's budget
it was one part of that we we could have
rolled the pitch better we've been open
about that that's why we've moved that
away with the welfare system as I say
the team at the department of work and
pensions and Cody Smith the Secretary of
State are working through that at a
moment and they will be making a
statement on that this awesome
all right let's carry on with the
cricket analogy tomorrow good morning he
always plays it with a straight bat
doesn't he
he always does K but I think even
Brandon Lewis trying to be positive
there couldn't really put a gloss on
what's been a very difficult
conservative conference and fresh from
the massive U-turn yesterday on the
decision to cut the 45p rate of tax
which the government now concede they
got wrong the problem with giving in is
that then the rebels then want more and
it's clear that the next Brewing
Rebellion is going to be about benefit
and the decision which is expected very
soon in the next few weeks about whether
to operate them to lift them by the
level of inflation from April next year
Richie sunac as Chancellor said that
would happen which would be about a 10
rise but it looks as if the government
are now trying to get away with a lower
rise perhaps at the level of average
earnings which is about five percent to
save several billion pounds that they'll
need to save in order to plug the black
hole created by some of these unfunded
tax cuts now you've got conservatives
publicly saying and just this morning a
cabinet minister Penny mordant said on
the radio that she thought it was the
right thing to do to lift benefits by
the level of inflation but some in
cabinet think that they can get away
with not doing it it looks like that may
not be the next big battle for Liz truss
and her Chancellor well we also learned
last night is that in another U-turn
quasi-quarter who had a difficult day
yesterday talking about a little
turbulence he has decided to bring
forward his plan to balance the books to
tell us where that money is going to
come from and what spending cuts will be
required to this month we'd heard it
would be the end of November but he's
now bringing it forward in order to give
the market some reassurance that does
also mean that some of these decisions
potentially including benefits will need
to be made pretty swiftly so that we get
a sense of exactly how much how much in
savings the government will have to find
so looks like a rocky road ahead for Liz
truss and her Chancellor absolutely the
polls are terrible again this small
morning and I believe that the Prime
Minister has been speaking to one of our
colleagues she's six times refused to
rule out a U-turn and then she's
speaking to conference tomorrow
yes Liz truss's big speech is tomorrow
um can she try to reset try and rally
support from her many uh critics in the
party we'll see if she has a much chance
of doing that the mood here is quite
Grim although you've got ministers
saying that she can that they've had a
terrible couple of weeks that they
understand that poll after poll after
Paul are showing massive leads for labor
they believe that they can turn things
around that now Liz truss has made that
U-turn she can concentrate on selling
her plan to freeze People's Energy bills
which they say is a sign that as Brandon
Lewis was saying there but she's on the
side of ordinary people but I've also
heard from veteran conservatives not
just people who supported britishly
sunac including people who supported
other candidates people who've been in
the party for a very long time saying
they haven't felt this depressed in 35
years as one former Minister was telling
me yesterday so look a big reassurance
job is going to need to be done and I
what I'm hearing a lot from MPS is Liz
trust doesn't just have to apologize for
what happened yesterday day she needs to
show she's learned from it so when she
makes her next announcement which is the
benefits announcement is coming soon
then you've got this big package of what
she calls deregulation measures to um to
save money on child care to shake up
planning they want to make sure those
have been fully worked through and
discussed with people first so there
aren't any more nasty surprises for her
MPS coming down the track yeah and as
far as the benefits are concerned um
tomorrow just your take on that as well
if you would please I mean the
difference between
um going with average pay Rises and
going with inflation is double isn't it
when it comes to benefits
absolutely Liz truss has given an
interview to LBC Radio this morning in
which she says she sort of hints that
she doesn't want to lift benefits by the
level of inflation saying that she
promised to lift pensions during her
leadership campaign by the level of
inflation because it's more difficult
for pensioners to get additional income
they really need that money from their
pensions whereas people on benefits can
take on more hours or take on a
different job now
I can tell you that some some of her own
ministers including in the cabinet
disagree with that and think that it's
important to raise the level of benefits
because people are going through such a
tough winter because regardless of this
freezing energy bills people are still
going to be paying more on their energy
bills than they were a year ago so she's
going to face a lot of opposition on
this it looks like Liz truss is gearing
up to say let's lift benefits only by
the level of average wages in order to
save probably around seven billion
pounds I think that's the the estimate
that's been around this morning but she
is going to face a Revolt if she does
not is she not able to bring MPS with
her on that then that will be another
expensive commitment that she will need
to find the money for and when talking
to people here about the prospect of
austerity the prospect of spending carts
they say they are worried that the
public will not want to stomach them and
public services like the NHS schools the
justice system simply I can't cope
already with the amount of funding that
they've currently got
okay for now thank you thanks so much
tomorrow
let's take a look at foreign policy now
with the defense committee chair that's
Tobias Elwood
um he is in Poland's Capital Warsaw um
hello to miss uh with thanks for joining
us on the program this morning it looks
as though your government first of all
has um steadied the ship I'm guessing
that will go down well with our
International partners
uh yeah it's important that the message
from Birmingham has heard around the
world I mean good government is all
about why is policy making it's about
the economic performance it's about
sowing political competence and that
needs to be seen across the world I'm
pleased that the chancellor recognized
and confirmed that not everything fell
into place and we are now making amends
but you know high growth that is key
that's the mission absolutely I mean
we've not had good productivity in the
UK since 2008 going back off so we need
bold leadership we need uh risk taking
we need to challenge the status quo but
you have to do that by Red teaming your
ideas by communicating by by motivating
and clearly there was no appetite for
those High tax breaks when we've already
borrowed 60 billion pounds rightly to
help pay the people with their energy
costs so I think it's so important that
we get the communications right now so
we can study the markets get the
interest rates down get our mortgages
down and should they remind Chancellor
remain in post
yes I think we need to see here his
fiscal statement in November I would
strongly encourage him to bring that
forward
um so we have greater stability greater
understanding of what's going on I think
you just share some of those ideas
behind the scenes beforehand I know
there's always a reluctance to do that
let's also have that obr report uh as
well but also I'd rather say standing
here in Warsaw where we're discussing
things in Ukraine you can no longer
write a budget without taking into
effect the international headwinds that
we Face we Embrace globalization but
globalization is now on the retreat you
cannot write a budget without perhaps
the National Security Council also
passing their eye over the facts you
want to get inflation down in the UK
then let's get those uh rain ships
modessa leaving that port on a more
regular basis that is the sort of thing
that we need to be thinking about not
just a siled approach to the UK
um you're in Poland rather than a
Birmingham at Cherry Party Conference
talking about Ukraine and other
defensive defense issues not least I'm
sure on your mind is the fact that North
Korea have been testing missiles over
Japan's I suppose
it comes next you know we did it when
the invasion was likely to take place
and we didn't make it clear what we
would do we should have actually
prevented it by going firm uh on
standing up to Russia and here we are
again questioning ourselves what might
or might happen might not happen uh if
Russia were to go down to use lonely
yield tactical nuclear weapons they are
starting to transport the equipment to
the front line we need to have a robust
debate about this and so what would
happen if a state in today's day and age
did
nuclear weapon
um well well I wondered if you also had
a view uh on the fact that
um King Charles has been told that he
can't go to cop 27 representing us on
the world stage the Prime Minister has
said she'd rather he didn't do you have
a thought
well you know climate change talking
about France is the biggest threat that
we face and we did such a fantastic job
but cop26 and Prince Charles as it then
was played a pivotal role you know we
talk about Britain's soft power it
doesn't become bigger than our royal
family and I do hope that Common Sense
will prevail that the king will be
allowed to attend this is such an
important meeting taking place cop 27
and some will shake in Egypt I would
strongly suggest that it isn't just the
king that goes but let's trust the Prime
Minister goes as well and you know
absolutely promotes the idea of global
Britain of us using our superpower soft
power status to encourage other
countries to recognize this huge threat
that we face
uh keep well thank you very much indeed
for joining us Tobias Elwood chairman of
the defense committee here in London in
the House of Commons Anthony Selden for
enter the program is with us you're
agreeing with him well I am I I mean the
monarchy is our greatest asset on the
world stage why a nurse would you want
to uh oppress suppress uh King Charles
particularly after the death of the
queen uh people will be wondering can
Britain do that again with a global
figure we have that in King Charles he's
got a longer track record on the
environment than just about any other
figure on the world stage why on Earth
would you want to suppress him from
speaking and reminding the rest of the
world that Britain is back with a
powerful voice on issues that truly
matter to the world because he might go
off script well he might go off script
uh but we know what his script is and
therefore it'd be hard to we know Off
Script is on script and it's on script
for the rest of the world it might be
embarrassing to have the head of state
upstaging the new prime minister here in
Britain but he's also a global figure
and surely it's going to help Britain
and also provide some some welcome good
stories for Britain at a time that let's
face it the stories in Britain are not
that great at the moment
um you know a lot about previous Prime
Ministers you've written about a lot of
them
um how quickly have previous Prime
Ministers find themselves doing u-turns
quicker than this one now uh this is uh
unusual
um unprecedented and unfortunate for
Britain not least uh with position in
the Ukraine at the moment it's an
unwelcome distraction uh the growth plan
that everyone agrees on most people
agree was necessary could have been done
with greater finesse and subtlety you
can't just uh come onto the stage and
think that you can uh have everybody
doing things your way and rip up what
previous people have done you have to
roll the pitch and that wasn't done so
the good uh in the package and uh there
was a great deal of good in it has
indeed uh been damaged by uh faulty
understanding and frankly a failure uh
to understand the way that the markets
and the way that the world of Finance
operates is it damaging when you have a
U-turn so early on especially when you
base yourself on a very Iron Lady from
and a speech from 40 years ago the
lady's not for turning but but I suppose
on the flip side you could say it's a
very different environment that we live
in now and it is a softer approach and
if you realize that you've done
something wrong it's okay as long as you
admit your mistake yes and chancellors
uh Gordon Brown came back from his 10p
income tax uh George Osborne from the
Pasty tax chancellors I mean neither
were as significant as this but
chancellors can come back Liz truss has
a great asset in that the party surely
cannot change yet another prime minister
and conservative party leader so soon
the party in the country would be up in
arms she has to show competence now she
has to avoid other mistakes she has to
build trust with the party she has to
soften her approach and show that she's
listening it may mean that the
chancellor does have to go and one will
see when the impact on inflation on
interest rates and whether the financial
plan is able to gain respect and
credibility in the markets if it doesn't
then it will look Bleak for him the
rules as they stand mean that she will
stay in post for a year unless those
rules are changed but as they stand she
must stay in post for a year before
there's any challenge to her being prime
minister even though she's more
unpopular than Boris Johnson was at any
time in his Premiership
yes I mean we ought to remember that
Theresa May recorded only nine percent
in the European elections I think was
the figure so things can go
catastrophically bad even in National
polls but look this is the absolute
nightmare for her she uh has wanted all
her life uh to do this and to do exactly
the things that she's done
um and so has quasi quateng it's it's um
I'm very unfortunate regrettable for
them on a personal level uh that they
happen to have their moment at precisely
not the moment to do what was that they
did uh can they row back they're going
to have to eat a great deal of Humble
Pie uh to show that they can empathize
with those who have power over them and
capitalize on the fact the party cannot
afford a change of uh prime minister and
probably can't afford a change of
Chancellor what does history tell us
about previous Prime Ministers who've
wanted to go go to the country for a
mandate or a better mandate
well recently not not encouraging so
Theresa May went in 2017
look every prime minister wants their
own mandate they don't want to be there
uh governing uh with the the credit in
the bank from their predecessor they
want to show that they've got their own
legitimacy and claim to power and their
own set of policies on which they can uh
then act
um Theresa may try to do that in 2017 uh
Fiasco but equally Gordon Brown was
blamed in 2008 for not doing that for
not getting his own uh mandate rather
than Tony Blairs back in 2005.
um and that blew up in his face because
he ducked the moment to go for an
election so I think it just shows that
being a prime minister is all but an
impossible office and job
um and if you do you're damned and if
you don't you're damned but she just has
to she just has to soften uh and it will
be very painful and very difficult for
her there is no way way back now she
tried to be like Margaret Thatcher she
tried to show that she was The Iron Lady
she now has to show that she's not just
a Teflon lady but also uh the the rubber
lady too who can uh Bend and listen uh
and go with what the party want because
they are her employers and what does um
history tell us about
previous
um governments in that you know we've
got we've had the Tories in power now
um for 12 years
um labor generally you know doesn't win
power we see Tori Tori Tori laboratory
territory labor labor potentially and
then so will is it a foregone conclusion
that they are so do so badly in the
polls at the moment that they really are
up against the ropes or is it for is it
in other words is it for labor to lose
or is it for labor to still still keep
pushing
well uh this is just the gift that keeps
on giving to Kia stammer whose own
authority in the party is much more
secure look you never want to become
prime minister at the period at the end
of a long period of ascendancy so Gordon
Brown that was very difficult for him
after 10 years of Labor in office same
with that sure same with absolutely with
John Major taking over from Thatcher you
will get blamed but in fact there are
many factors that make it very difficult
not least the burnout of talent and the
country wants to have and commentators
want to have a fresh set of faces
um it's very difficult when that time
for a change comes up so Liz truss
anyway was coming on to a wicket to use
a curriculum analogy that was pretty
ripped up uh but by slogging uh the
first ball that she had and being caught
in the Gully uh that wasn't a great
start she can now just simply soften
some often and show competence and show
she's listening but no one party has
ever won since the beginning of
democracy in 1832 five elections on a
trot with that and with 25 30 down in
the polls and with uh the budget uh so
early on such a fiasco uh if you were
betting you would be a very brave person
to bet on the conservatives winning a
majority in late 2024 or even January
25. your cricketing analogy will be very
useful for our American viewers this
morning I didn't particularly for your
American viewers
exactly and so um if you had a crystal
ball your prediction would be
uh for the election uh that starmer is
now looking the talk was of him being in
Coalition that he'll win uh with a
majority of 30. okay good to talk to you
thank you Mr Anthony thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
thank you quick look at the weather for
you
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
next few days will bring wind and rain
but Southeastern Britain looks mainly
fine today uh it's mild but windy now
with prolonged and sometimes Heavy Rain
pushing across Scotland into Northern
England and Wales there are some drizzly
outbreaks for Northern Ireland and
Ireland too
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now is trust so she is going to take a
responsible approach to handling the
public finances amid a fresh battle
against Tory rebels over the level of
benefit earlier the Justice secretary
Brandon Lewis tell me the prime minister
is working for the benefit of the
country despite admitting the government
could have rolled the pitch better on
its mini budget
my experience of working with prime
minister is she tends to focus on what
is right for the country and what is
going to get the best outcome for people
right across our country look we do work
in a parliamentary democracy that means
we have to work with Parliament we've
got to make sure that what we're doing
can pass in Parliament as well that's
just a reality of a parliamentary
democracy I saw I heard the a click from
what Graham was saying to you earlier
and Grant was making the point even with
welfare benefits it's about making sure
that whatever you do you're clear about
what the argument is that you can show
people why what you're doing is the
right thing as I say with quasi's budget
it was one part of that we we could have
rolled the pitch better we've been open
about that that's why we've moved that
away with welfare system as I say the
team at the department of work and
pensions and Cody Smith the Secretary of
State are working through that at a
moment and they will be making a
statement on that this awesome
check out these pictures women and girls
being taught that not even the sky is
the limit by the International Space
Station's first female European
Commander here we go
fantastic features uh Samantha
christopheretti took a doll made in her
likeness aboard the ISS and took video
questions from girls back here on Earth
she encouraged them to study science
technology engineering and of course
mathematics
that's fantastic also
um
let's tell you about Ringo Starr should
we his band have taken their show off
the road after the former Beetle tested
positive for kovid 19.
[Applause]
playing in Mount Pleasant in Michigan
last Friday for now though the North
American tour by Ringo Starr and his
all-star band is on hold while the 82
year old recovers they say they hope to
be back on stage very soon
now coming up a snapshot of the poles
with a Tory pier and a pollster we've
been looking at those poles again before
you remember at the beginning of the
week when it came to yougov the
conservatives were 30 points behind
labor that was the end of last week
actually wasn't it and that was even
before the mini budget had been baked in
so uh labor [ __ ] a hoop about that there
have been more polls since then on
average the Tories between 20 and 25
points behind labor what does that mean
for the Prime Minister she'll be
speaking to our own Beth Rigby later on
uh today and then
um speaking to conference tomorrow a lot
of the big players former big players
are no longer at conference this year
including David Davis and also the
former deputy prime minister
um that Dominic Raab he has also decided
that conference is not the place for him
to buy zelwood we were just chatting to
him on the program he hasn't gone either
what is in store for the Prime Minister
reflect single nuts in just a moment
here on Sky news station
[Music]